need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back I lack a belief
in yourself so get ready for some focus
shifting wisdom from Tim Ferriss to give
you the motivation confidence and belief
that you need
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one focus on one thing there's a I want
to say it might be a philosophers
paradox but I don't think it is I think
it's just parable about burdens ass so
burdens ass about a donkey yeah it's
about a donkey who is thirsty and hungry
and there's water on one side few feet
away
and hang on the other and he can't
decide whether to do the hey first the
hey first or the water the hey or the
water and he dies of thirst at the end
of it he couldn't do them sequentially
you can do almost everything you want in
life but you can't do it at the same
time right and if you can just dedicate
yourself to one thing for even a year
and then the next thing for a year you
can do those 10 things but if you try to
do all 10 at once you're gonna be
burdens s you know should I do this
should I do this or should I focus on
this [ __ ] worse than this so don't be a
donkey
rule number two conquer fear so when I
was interviewing Jamie Foxx for duels of
titans I asked him how he developed
confidence in his kids he's one of the
most confident human beings I've ever
met and he said that whenever they were
facing fear weren't afraid of something
stressed about something he would say
what's on the other side of fear he
would ask them that and then he paused
and he'd say nothing nothing's on the
other side of fear meaning that if you
dissect your fears if you name them and
study them they lose their power and the
way I translate that is with something
called fear setting in my own life
rather than goal setting
that's fine but you can't be driving
around with the emergency brake on so
fear settings very simple I look at the
I take a piece of paper I divide it into
three columns at the top might put what
I'm afraid of
and the decision whatever I think is
risky or scary first column all the
worst things that could happen in detail
the worst things could happen second
column for each of those bullets what I
could do to minimize the likelihood of
them happening and then last column for
each bullet if they happen how could I
get back to where I am now if you do
this exercise what you end up doing is
completely disarming your fears because
you've made them very very specific
you've taken them from hazy to extremely
clear and that allows you to take risks
and do incredible things simply because
you've removed the emergency brake rule
number three practice pronunciation
I found out recently that Elon Musk went
I think was in college 30 days on one
dollar a day
did he really to teach himself that he
could do it Kevin Kelley one of my I
would consider him a mentor certainly
he's in the book I mean my my vote or
one of my votes for the real world most
interesting man in the world fascinating
guy he's got an Amish beard built his
own house technology futurist who can
predict all sorts of crazy things that
are coming down the line even though he
never went already dropped out of school
his story is just nuts and Kevin also at
periods of time would go on extended
backpacking trips he still does mean
he's gotta be in the 70s now travels
with his kids quite a bit and his wife
and he'll go say a week of sleeping in a
sleeping bag just eating oatmeal and
nothing else that's it saw my tent
oh yeah right yeah I sleep in that tab
yeah and you do that every once in
awhile I try to do something like that
at least a few days a month I almost
always fast at least three days and
months contiguous days a month which you
do need to be careful with you can
yourself up so have someone qualified
supervise you for stuff like that but
when you practice the the removal of of
wants when you have a renunciation
practice of some type or an aesthetic
practice of some time cold exposure also
one of my favorites although it's it's
not really the same cat
you you begin to teach yourself not or
realize in some cases not only can you
survive if say sleeping in the tent or
going a week just having like instant
coffee and oatmeal and a sleeping bag
but for anyone who's gone from say the
hustle-bustle grind grind grind to like
a seven to ten day hiking trip how good
do you feel after that you don't just
survive you feel so revived from it
number four take action so Derek Siver's
is this like programmer monk philosopher
king startup entrepreneur and said derek
has as a couple of one-liners that I
think are really fantastic one is if
more information were the answer we'd
all be billionaires with six-pack abs
that's a good one yeah and you just just
just absorbing not even absorbing just
reading and watching and listening to
more isn't enough like you have to apply
it you have to use incentives you have
to have rewards and punishments set for
yourself so you actually get things done
timelines etc also if you want to have
more confidence check in my 250 for
series they're free the links to join
are in the description below a lot of
the anxiety that we feel is actually due
to using words that are not defined very
well in fact I think you should ask
yourself first and foremost why do you
create content self-love is not an
indulgence it's not a nice-to-have
it is a prerequisite rule number five
use intuition I'm trying to increasingly
use intuition intuition helps me to
identify things that I would like to
test even if they seem ridiculous so for
instance every time I've had a roommate
in a foreign country where I'm using
comic books to learn a language I get
ridiculed every single time they're like
wham pow
smash really like that's what you're
gonna and and then three months later
there are convert because they see I'm
studying dialogue that's why the comic
books work the same reason that scripts
if you can get translated scripts for
movies which you can very easily work so
well for language learning intuition is
oftentimes just
a a proxy for interest so if I'm really
interested in something that checks the
box partially of the stakes and
incentives right rule number six
pause almost all of my most if you
bought a look at it from a professional
standpoint like my most incredibly
critical professional opportunities and
decisions have come from slack in the
calendar all right so they're the the
must do things that are important like
we talked about that for instance some
of these things that I've put on the
calendar for the next month or two but
beyond that because that's the most
important thing beyond that after
something like this a book launch or a
TV show launch or whatever it might be I
leave a lot of the calendar open because
I cannot whatever I might plan
I assume cannot take into account this
the incredible and fascinating things
and people that will come out of the
woodwork as a result of say mmm I'll
launch like this so I just create this
space for that all of my best
investments if you look it like Twitter
Facebook Boober Alibaba all this stuff
they all came from gaps in the system
yeah not through some crazy grand design
yeah whiteboarding how this is gonna go
no no I mean if it's it's from me and I
had a conversation with Tim O'Reilly
recently on my podcast which was so much
fun for people who don't know him you
can check him out he's he's considered
or he's been nicknamed the trend spotter
in Silicon Valley a really good guy and
he spends a lot of time just sitting in
stillness and just listening and that's
either gonna make some semblance of
sense to people or it's not I won't try
really dig into it but through
meditation and other things he's for
instance on his one habit that his most
positively impacted his life in the last
year or so is on his morning runs he
goes running every morning he makes it a
point every morning he goes on a run to
stop and take a photograph of a flower
mm-hmm and that's an example of just
like stopping an expert
sing some stillness and then he'll just
pause for a second and then continue on
his run and I'm sure I think I've spent
so much time yelling at myself
internally for so much of my life there
was very little stillness and now I'm
taking time and look I still have my
monkey mind I still have both the
bounces around in my skull and when I
sit down and meditate for those people
who might be wondering like if I
meditate for 20 minutes I would say 19
minutes of that it's just like to-do
list
porn stupid argument imaginary
hypothetical discussion I might have
it's just nonsense
and then there are like 30 seconds from
like oh this is possible like this this
state of stillness is actually possible
however brief and learning to instead of
constantly yelling at myself just like
pause rule number seven use anger to
fuel you what makes you angry was one of
the key pieces of advice that I was
given by writer named Poe Bronson when I
asked him what do you do when you have
writer's block he said what makes you
angry we're just right that and that was
also the advice that I was given by
Whitney Cummings and a few other
stand-up comedians how do you develop
material what makes you angry right
about that so I think anger as opposed
to just labeling it a bad thing can be
very useful fuel so what makes you angry
and let's just say you're writing about
something that doesn't require or seem
to require anger well if you're if you
can't get started it doesn't matter so
write about something else write about
what makes you angry and either you'll
be able to sort of parry that into this
other subject when once you get going or
you'll end up writing something
completely different and lend up better
in the first place rule number eight
journal a five minute journal popped up
a lot and that is something takes five
minutes in the morning five minutes at
night
another one was morning pages everyone
from say Brian Koppelman The Illusionist
billions amazing screenwriter and
producer as well he's given morning
pages as just one instance so three
freehand pages
I think he's recommended to about a
hundred people ten have taken them up on
it and he said somewhere between seven
and nine have had multiple hit shows
mult
we'll hit movies multiplet books it's a
really impressive actress and this is a
daily exercise that you wake up before
you get your day going is it important
that it's in that window I would say
it's important that it's before you're
in a reactive mode so before you're
dodging bullets of text and email this
is part of a very typical morning
routine for these folks and for me now
yeah where I'll just I will do my
meditation steep some tea sit down my
tea in the fight and the five minute
journal or morning pages yeah and that
sets the stage if you win the morning
you win the day rule number nine learn
to say no and were one of the best
pieces of advice I ever received related
to negotiation was super simple someone
said to me he who cares less wins if you
have walkaway power are the ability to
just say no so another based on that in
part I also developed a rule for myself
which I follow I have followed very very
very consistently which is if so if
someone tries to pressure to meet me to
make a decision quickly the answer's no
if you want if you want a knee-jerk
response if someone's like that's
closing tomorrow or subscribe I don't
know like like either yes or no now like
I'm not gonna leave until you say yes to
X um ugh then the answer's no absolutely
no hmm it's like any on-the-spot
decision that you want me to make or
forcing me to make answer's no and
there's tremendous power in them and
it's a muscle that you strengthen as you
practice it and you realize like oh like
the world didn't end right and it's not
just it's not that you don't care like
it's more that you're not defined by the
outcome or you're not attached you don't
have an expectation around the outcome
like you know that you're good outside
of however this goes down yeah and rule
number 10 the last one before very
special bonus clip is have fun all right
Tim Ferriss here playing the dry-ice
that I received in my Omaha Steaks box
didn't know what to do so I sent a tweet
out to my readers in Rob Knight told me
to experiment as he did it as a science
teacher with room temperature coins and
dry ice so I could have groove
into the ice with my Kershaw Assist open
knife and you can see here vibrates like
that Hillary - holder so it's it's
freezing cold be careful you don't
freeze these to your fingers like I did
a minute ago well if I take a warm coin
I can press it listen to this hold and
then it stops thought it was air
vibrations but I think has something to
do with the temperature so let's try a
different approach I have a cup of
reasonably warm water here oh don't do
that and then I'm going to grab piece of
dry ice here oh this is not as refined
as mr. science you drop that in then you
have instant fog look at that how cool
is that and if you look inside I'll try
to show you guys this all the boiling
bubbles are white which is pretty sweet
so you have instant fog machine in your
house and then what's really cool which
I did has a very interesting visual
effect is you slowly pour it out so
watch this it's not half as cool looking
at it from that perspective but it's
pretty neat to pour it out the sink you
have all this fog throughout the house
that's my indoor atrium over there I'll
show you that while we're doing this as
you can see I have more or less a rain
forest 20 to 30 feet of plants in there
so I can oxygenate
and that's the end of our science show
for this evening
Thanks readers bluh-bluh-bluh-bluh-bluh
[Music]
now I've got a special bonus gift from
Tim on how to convert your flaws into
strengths that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to take an
action here we go question number one
what do you need to learn to say no to
number two what is your intuition
telling you that you need to listen to
and number three how can you use anger
to fuel you copy write your faults and
of course there are weaknesses you
should address but then there are flaws
that can be converted into strengths so
I think that's that's another way to
catalyze creativity or just creating
anything is to realize that some of your
biggest flaws may in fact be assets and
so that could be a question you ask
right how might some of my biggest
weaknesses be strengths or assets I
think that's a very useful question to
journal on and which I which I tend to
do just about every morning
if you want 10 more rules from Tim
Ferriss check out their video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
feel we could never possibly emulate
because I have it all figured out there
you have no insecurities they wake up
every morning and with a mental karate
chop they just master the day that's not
how it works